a more restrictive way of life
is about to sweep across the country in
bristol
sergeant luke keenan and pc jamie john
are out on patrol covid 19 has brought
new challenges
but for most people a nudge in the right
direction
is all that it takes do you have any
face masks with you today
because because it's an enclosed sort of
shopping process you should really have
them on
we're looking to engage with the public
first and foremost and to actually
remind them that this is their social
responsibility that they need to take
and actually yes we will enforce it but
at the same time
we just by walking through here today
i've seen a number of people
put their face masks on straight away as
soon as they've seen us and actually
that's really positive
so enforcing the new order as the darker
months grind on
will require careful policing but will
it be enough
for the new measures to work compliance
is going to be everything but there is a
sense in this city at least that
confidence in the government's handling
of the pandemic is wearing thin
and whilst most people will follow the
rules there's also a sizeable minority
that resents the extra restrictions
on their daily lives and there's no
doubt
for many people learning to live with
another new normal
will be frustrating for them to
you know say eat how to help out we'll
pay for some of it everyone goes out
and then they're blaming the young
people and everything i think everyone's
just a bit sick and tired like
as you said it's very inconsistent i
think so do you think compliance is
going to be a problem this time
i struggle to believe anything the
government says nowadays i don't think
i'm on my own with that either
and you won't follow the guidelines
because you don't believe them i don't
know
it's tough i mean i'll follow them when
it suits me i have been following all of
them
i just i just think that the problems
because being caused by a small minority
like in the pubs at night you see him in
the streets holding hands and kissing
and drinking
whatever happens next it will be a long
winter
but the government is threatening if
these measures don't work
a second lockdown could be on its way
alex rossi sky news bristol